thank you very much maria the
announcement of the security pact
between china and the solomon islands
came as a surprise to australia's prime
minister
we're very concerned for solomon islands
we're very concerned for the broader
security in the southwest pacific the
agreement will see beijing increase ties
with the pacific islanders and help to
safeguard national security the
australian government warns the pact
threatens regional stability and allows
china to expand militarily in the
pacific the island's prime minister
declared he's on the right side of
history by forging closer ties with
beijing
we are being treated as kindergarten
students walking around with cold 45s in
our hands and therefore we need to be
supervised
we are insulted the ongoing fallout over
the pact has dominated the election
campaign with recriminations on both
sides
the coalition government has vowed to
increase funding for aid and economic
development to reassure ireland nations
of australian support
the opposition says it will establish a
stronger diplomatic network to resist
china's expansion
the region is changing very quickly
around us
and what we're seeing is perhaps that
australian policy
is a bit slow to catch up to it it's not
to say that the concerns haven't been
there but there's a certain
there's an incrementalism
to china's strategic push
australia and the united states fear the
pact could see china establish a naval
base less than two thousand kilometers
from the australian coast
a former senior colonel in china's
people's liberation army says that's
alarmist i think it is important and
irresponsible for the
head of a nation to describe the
legitimate cooperation
sovereign states as across the red line
he's not entitled to say that
a delegation from china including the
foreign minister is expected to visit
honiara as early as next week if the
tour goes ahead it will coincide with
high-level quad talks between australia
japan india and the united states in
tokyo analysts say that's a deliberate
attempt by beijing to try and overshadow
their dialogue
it's also another sign china is intent
on cementing stronger security and
economic ties across the indo-pacific
sarah clark al jazeera sydney australia